vous avez vraiment tout fait à chaque
fois on lui faisait croire que les faire
des trucs de ouf
et à chaque fois ils tombent dans le
panneau jamais vous êtes douter non
parce que c'est super bien fait vous
êtes hyper convaincant je vous ai
toujours sa confiance j'ai pas toujours
eu raison
non là franchement c'est normal sur les
grosses lignes oui ça va absolument et
puis en fait on est tellement pris quand
ce qu'on dit sien au pire
après si c'est un gag voilà mais on se
conditionnent un truc de fou quoi ça
regardez ça c'est un de mes moments mais
dans les moments de gilles exceptionnel
j'en ai pleuré
ces partis compile j'ai dit à mes potes
ce week-end que je faisais rentrée ce
garçon dans la bande et julio là c'est
le procureur le procureur ici on vous
appellera pas le procureur eh bien vous
appellera je ne vous appellera pas
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
q où coule tout sert elle
ça a très bien su plein de fientes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raté ridicule
ces deux crétins ne comprennent rien à
la vouli est un festival de conneries
pas comprenez rien pas de surprise pas
de mouvement pas d'originalité pas de
production décalée catane décalé catane
l'apam à nous prendre pour des cons
tu m'as dit non qui a dit non et j'ai
défoncé ce que vous pouvez résumé ce que
dit tirer vos objets jetés de la merde
citons a dans le pantalon de l'ong
judiciaire paraît millions tu viendras
pas parce que t'as jamais rien eu dans
le pantalon et dolo sarem avec paul
tronchet avant le coeur très très tendre
et la tob très très dur sans je vois ça
franchement j'ai mal à ma france de
l'ormeau fais ce que tu as fait hier et
la décence de fermer ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
/
je t'aime mon bébé je vais faire la vie
la plus belle des modesties
alors ça c'était pour la ville en
plateau mais le meilleur moment elle
frôlait le joli c'est la piscine et le
canon est ce que le rap et du canot les
gagnants mais bien sûr qu annonce était
et je voulais vous dire qu'il s'est
passé à san mamés mais parce qu'il a
glissé voit le voit d'ailleurs sortir du
tapis est arrivé sur les tapis
secondaires assez à 50 cm je pense à
n'était pas loin de l'endroit de
l'accident et que rien sur rien on
regarde gilles attendent sur gilles
syrie je vous aime vous êtes ses rythmes
aussi je vous aime comme un frère merci
j alors j'ai l'on va allumer la mèche du
canot rampe [ __ ] [ __ ] j'ai l'eau va
allumer la mèche du calen sayal est
allumée gilles vous allez partir dans un
instant les bouchers du tout je t'aime
tarifs à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je suis moi je pensais vraiment on avait
passé une vidéo
moi je pensais vraiment que j'allais
faire 50 ou 60 m j'avais vu le filet à
60 mais j'étais allé demander aux gars
mais vous êtes sûr que je peux faire 60
mme anne marie brigitte est parti là